now sakia starmer described a day of
shame for labour as he accepted all the
findings of an investigation into its
failure to deal with anti-semitism but
now he's facing more pressure from
within the party
following the suspension of his
predecessor jeremy corbyn
he also had the whip withdrawn for his
response to the report's
findings now there's talk of a civil war
emerging within labour well let's talk
to sakiya stamina now
very good morning to you first and
foremost on the back of what jeremy
corbyn said yesterday is there
yet another need for the labour party to
apologize to the
jewish community well i apologized
uh yesterday in clear terms
i also apologized on the first day i
took over as leader of the
labour party for our failure to deal
with anti-semitism
the findings in the commission's report
yesterday were
clear and rigorous there were findings
of
unlawful action and the right thing to
do in my view is to accept in full
the findings of the commission to
apologize and recognize
the hurt and grief that it has caused
jewish people
in the united kingdom um and to be
absolutely committed to carrying out the
recommendations
in a short period of time and that's
what was my response and
i had hoped yesterday would be if you
like a line in the
sand i'd spoken to many jewish
communities jewish community leaders
that's what they wanted they wanted the
labour party to recognize the hurt and
pain
accept the findings and to move on
um to rebuild trust with the jewish
community that is my
absolute commitment i had hoped that
that's how yesterday would have gone
unfortunately because of the comments of
jeremy corbyn in response to the report
the day's events took a different turn
do you think now in the light of that
that jeremy corbyn is
an anti-semite or at least has said
things
yesterday which were anti-semitic well
the
report was a full report and it made no
individual findings
against jeremy corbyn it's very
important that i say that and make that
absolutely
um clear i was disappointed in jeremy's
response
yesterday particularly since i had said
in my response
that the labour party will not tolerate
anti-semitism
nor will it tolerate those who deny it
as a problem of anti-semitism and say
it's all exaggerated or
factional because that for me is part of
the problem
so i was disappointed in jeremy's
response it is now subject to
an investigation and the one thing i've
learned from the report yesterday is
that
the leader of the labour party should
now not comment
um any further let the process take its
course
one of the findings in the report
yesterday was that there had been um
interference from the
labour leaders office in individual
cases that shouldn't happen
and i'm not going to make that mistake
but but to go back to the point do you
think his
his his claims of over exaggeration of
the anti-semitic
issue for political gain as he put it
do you think that comment by him was in
itself anti-semitic
well you're inviting me to comment on
the very issue that's being investigated
but i can tell you in general terms how
i saw this or i see this
because i made that clear um yesterday
and that is
that if you're anti-semitic then you
shouldn't be in the labour party
if you are in denial about um
anti-semitism in the labour party and
say it's all whipped up it's exaggerated
it's just
factional fighting then that is part of
the problem
too i said it yesterday i've actually
said it before
because that only adds to the grief and
pain
of those that have already been affected
by the failure to deal with
anti-semitism
over the last few years which is why i
was disappointed
with the response of jeremy corbyn
yesterday morning okay
well you've been very clear on that so
where does that leave people like
len mccluskey who obviously is is head
of
your biggest donor the united union i
mean he's he's previously
previously said there was no
anti-semitism
problem within the labour party he is
obviously back jeremy corbyn from what
happened yesterday
can you still take his money well um
what led mccluskey is concerned about is
that there shouldn't be
a split in the labour party um
and he's right about that i don't want
to split in the labour party
i stood um as leader of labour party on
the basis that i would
unite the party but also that i would
tackle anti-semitism i think both of
those can be done
there's no reason for a civil war in our
party
but we are absolutely determined i'm
absolutely determined
to root out anti-semitism i don't want
the words
labor and labour party and anti-semitism
in the same sentence again
that's about rebuilding trust that's my
job
that's the job of the labor leadership
now i know that
the jewish communities are looking at me
and they're saying very clearly we will
judge you by what you do
not by what you say and they're right
about that but i'm determined to restore
that
trust and we can have a united labor
party around
the forgive me for it forgive me for
interrupting forgive me for interrupting
but are you
on a personal level then in the light of
all you've said
this morning are you comfortable with
what len mccluskey said yesterday
well len is um i spoke to len uh
yesterday he is concerned um but there
shouldn't be a civil war in the labour
party
as am i and there's no need for that and
i think that
it's the responsibility of all of us to
work forward in a way that
unites our party but i will not renege
on my commitment
to root out anti-semitism in the labour
party
but he has said there was he has
previously said there wasn't an issue
with anti-semitism within the labor
party
well and i've previously said that
denying this a problem is part of the
problem but so can you send
his money len mccluskey and i do not
want to split in the labour party nobody
in the labour party wants splits or
arguments
we need to be united in the labour party
but we must
not pull back from the commitment to
root out anti-semitism
you will see though sakir what you how
people watching this will say
you know you you you're prepared or the
party is prepared to take a very strong
line
against individuals but but not wanting
to take a particularly strong line
with the head of the union which is
providing you with millions of pounds
look i mean i've been leader for six
months i've already brought about change
and i've made some very difficult
decisions
uh that frankly people didn't think i
would make
so i don't really think that the
suggestion that
somehow i'm not strong on anti-semitism
and i'm not going to deal with this
is a fair reflection of the last six
months
wherever issues uh are um raised
they are now dealt with properly by the
complaints process
and they will be
again can i just get a clear answer on
the money side you're happy are you
to keep taking money from unite whose
leader
has said there isn't a problem with
anti-semitism within the labour party
well uh len mccluskey wasn't saying
yesterday that there isn't a problem
with anti-semitism he said that
previously when he said it previously i
said that
saying this whole thing is part of the
problem but he didn't say that yesterday
he recognizes
what the problem is i spoke to len
mccluskey yesterday he recognizes
the anti-semitism in the labour party he
doesn't want to split
in the labour party i think we can have
a united party
but we must also tackle anti-semitism
um well the the report was was very
clear
wasn't it and you said you've accepted
it in terms of how this was
dealt with uh prior to your appointment
as leader
and the reflection on that is that it
was that it was not handled well that
and as you said as jeremy corbyn
appeared to intervene in some cases
that should have been been handled by
the the party executive
in the light of that you still
campaigned for him to be
uh our prime minister at the end of last
year
why did you do that why did you stand
with him why didn't you step down from
the shadow cabinet
well jeremy corbyn was twice elected
leader of the labour party he had a
clear mandate
i served in the shadow cabinet as the
shadow brexit secretary dealing with the
brexit negotiations within the shadow
cabinet and
actually outside on media including i
think on sky
i spoke out about anti-semitism i
thought it was right to raise it
inside the shadow cabinet and outside
the shadow cabinet
but there's no getting away from the
findings of the report yesterday
they are clear findings and we all have
to accept them including myself
which is why i thought the right
response yesterday was to accept the
findings to apologize again
for the hurt that had been caused and to
make it my absolute business
to implement the recommendations as
quickly as possible and that's why
we've already agreed an action plan will
be put before the commission within six
weeks
setting out what action practical steps
we will take
on the back of the report you're a very
clever man you must have had some
inkling as to what was going on while
you were serving in the shadow cabinet
i mean did you let yourself down by
staying in position
i think there was a lot of challenge
within the shutter cabinet believe you
me
on issues of the role changes on the
international
definition where there should be
automatic expulsion of those that have
been
anti-semitic i was very clear in those
discussions i was very clear outside of
the shadow cabinet
on the media that's a matter of record i
thought we needed voices in and outside
the shadow cabinet
but the findings yesterday our findings
um
in relation to the labour party to the
collective leadership
we all need to accept them including me
um and that is why i apologized
yesterday
it's also why i apologize is the first
thing i did as labour leader on the 4th
of
april when i set out my apology in my
acceptance speech
and set out my commitment that as the
labour leader it was my
duty to root out anti-semitism and i'm
not going to shirk from that duty
what did you make of your deputy's
comments yesterday when when she said
jeremy corbyn has a blind spot
when it comes to this issue well angela
rainer knows
uh jeremy very well um and um
i was disappointed as she was in
jeremiah's response
yesterday i don't want to get too far
into the criticism of the response
because that is a matter of the
due process now but but andrew and i
spoke extensively yesterday we were both
really disappointed with the response
this was a day
i had hoped where the labour party could
draw a line a painful
day of course in light of the findings
but
draw a line and move forward and i know
that's what
jewish communities wanted they wanted us
to accept the report
and to move forward on the
recommendations that is how i had hoped
yesterday
would play out um it didn't
and that's why angela rayner said what
she did it's why she and i were very
disappointed and obviously she and i
uh worked very closely yesterday as we
always do it always
it's almost that i mean you can
understand k i mean come on
from your your previous career you can
understand how that almost sounds sort
of slightly apologetic
well of course i mean i'm i am
apologetic i've apologized
forgive me forgive me you've you've
misunderstood sort of
apologetic towards jeremy corbyn or it's
just a bit of a blind spot
oh no look i i don't think answers being
apologetic in any
shape or form look the decision that was
taken yesterday
was the right decision but it was a
difficult decision
just as there have been other difficult
decisions in the last six months
and the one thing angela rainer and i
have been absolutely clear about as
as as the leader and deputy leader of
the parties we are not going to shy away
from difficult decisions
yesterday was a very difficult decision
for the labour party
it was the right decision we now need to
let the investigation take its course
but i don't think
in light of the decision was taken
yesterday anybody could say we're being
apologetic on the contrary i think many
people are saying
i didn't think that the labour party
would take such a difficult
decision we did because of our
commitment to rooting out anti-semitism
you've talked about not wanting a split
in the labour party you've talked about
len mccluskey not wanting a split in the
labour party
if it is necessary if a split is
actually necessary
to to save the labour party from these
calls of anti-semitism and
some some form of the the sort of racist
undertones of all of that would you be
prepared to split the party
i don't think it's necessary and my job
is to
unite the party i don't think it's
necessary and i don't think
it will happen we need to work together
the vast majority
of labour party members and supporters
are horrified by what's going on in
relation to anti-semitism
and the findings in the report yesterday
they want to pull together
they want to see united party and we
will work to that end
but it has to sit alongside the
commitment
to root out anti-semitism because that
is a matter of values
and trust and confidence that goes way
beyond
the question of simply winning an
election or not it goes to the heart of
what the labour party is
in in terms of of the heart of what the
labour party is i mean
you'll have seen in the papers this
morning there is there is lots of talk
as to whether
you are having a purge of the militant
faction as
as neil kinnick did back in the 80s
are you trying to to drag the labour
party back to its heart as you see it
i'm not purging um anybody or any group
within
the labour party what i'm being very
clear about is that the labour party
that i
lead will not tolerate anti-semitism
full stop nor will it tolerate those
that say
anti-semitism in the labour party
doesn't really exist it's exaggerated
or it's just a factional war whipped up
in or outside the labour party including
by
the media so i'm being very clear
about that but i'm not in the business
of purging anyone
from the labour party i'm in the
business of taking difficult decisions
to follow through on a commitment that i
made not just to our jewish communities
but to the british public
but as leader of the labour party i
would tackle anti-semitism
and i'm absolutely determined to do that
sakia stalmer we appreciate your time
today thank you
thank you